pawn was captured white's rook would
have gone to the top of the board that
was a fantastic move by juwen june and
she's forced the black king away now
i think she's in time to just
is she in time to trade off this black
dart squad bishop and win the game
big moment here she's got 30 seconds to
calculate all she needs to do is get rid
of black star squared bishop and promote
her pawn or at least win one of black's
bishops in the process
she has time right how can she get rid
of that bishop i think she has time go
and trade it off this is what she's
doing wow what a move and now by zhu
june she checked away the black king and
now she's trying to eliminate this black
piece and i think she's winning if the
black bishop trades itself off then
suddenly white is promoting first white
promotes with check the key detail is
that if black bishop gives itself up
then suddenly this black pawn is about
to promote but white is just in time one
move in time to stop the pawn um if we
catch up with the game
wow she's about to win she just gave a
check and she's making a new queen we
have a result the queen the chess queen
wins it by making a new queen fantastic
what a result